all right let's jump into audience
questions for the week love getting
questions from people in the audience
these are more curated than live calls
as some of you may have noticed then
people sometimes like both sometimes
like these sometimes prefer the live
calls because they're more spontaneous
let's go to the first one and then we
can evaluate first question today David
now that the midterms are over what's
next for the left should we be working
within the Democratic Party up until
2020 or should we be working outside of
the 20 of the Democratic Party who
should run in 2020 for the Democrats
okay so let's start with the
inside-outside thing
the debate over inside or outside the
Democratic Party has been actually
growing a lot in the last seven to ten
days and what people often mean by work
within or outside of the Democratic
Party is do we try as progressives to
move the Democratic Party to the left
with the idea that the Democratic Party
still is the path forward for
progressivism in the United States or do
we abandon the Democratic Party and try
to foment progressivism in the United
States by working within third parties
I've talked to you about this before I
don't like the two-party duopoly in the
United States that being said it's gonna
be very tough at the federate the
national level for real third party
success until number one you have some
kind of serious campaign finance reform
and number two I would argue you have
some kind of rank choice voting put in
place I know that some people standard
rank choice voting they don't like
because you can end up with somebody
who's no one's first choice winning
there are other tweaked versions that
solve that problem so I think that for
me path the path forward is at the local
level absolutely particularly in
nonpartisan elections or elections where
it doesn't matter you don't necessarily
designate or run on a party platform
let's get people from third parties
involved let's start moving in the
direction of it not mattering whether
you're a Democrat if you're progressive
that you can
when that's gonna start at the local
level I think the unfortunate reality
and this is where I know people will get
mad at me pat and say I am a blind
pragmatist the pragmatic element of my
personality tells me that at the federal
level right now there are more
opportunities to move the Democrats to
the left pushing for congressional
candidates to not accept PAC money as
ROH Khanna and some others have chosen
to do I think there are more practical
opportunities there than saying we're
abandoning the Democratic Party and
we're going third party I just think
that it's just not going to work both
our uphill battles that's for sure but I
think that the path of least resistance
is a progressive takeover of the
Democratic Party I think that's that's
certainly easier to do because many
people are not willing to educate
themselves on some of these third
parties they're gonna enter the voting
booth and either check their the the box
that says D or check the box that says R
and that's just how most people operate
and I also think that if there was ever
a chance for a third party to do well it
would have been the 2016 election
because you had Donald Trump versus
Hillary Clinton two of the most if not
the most unpopular candidates of all
time and we didn't see that we didn't
see Gary Johnson or Jill Stein really
get any traction so I I think that the
easiest thing to do and it's not easy
but easiest is to try to take over the
Democratic Party and push it to the left
the the other sort of element that I
think is important about this is that if
you have progressive ideas coming from
third parties it makes it much easier
for the Democratic Party to ignore those
and to keep the Overton Window centered
straddling the the political spectrum
exactly as it does right now once you
inject more progressive ideas to the
Democratic Party's discussion I believe
that they have less of a simple means by
which they can ignore the fact that
these progressive ideas are getting more
attention case in point if there was no
discussion of medicare-for-all within
the Democratic Party if you only saw
medicare-for-all discussion relegated to
third parties and the furthest
that you got in the Democratic Party on
healthcare was a public option for
example you would have a Democratic
Party that was even more to the right of
where it is right now on this issue so I
think that there is this you I've talked
about the term unilateral radicalization
unilateral unilateral movement to the
right by extremists on the rights I
don't think that we need Stalinist
Leninists on the left in order to
progressive eyes the discussion on the
left you just need serious social
democracy on the left the ideas of
Bernie Sanders when it comes to college
and health insurance and so on and so
forth and that is going to immediately
put the Democratic Party in a position
to explain why they are ignoring these
voices if they are and if you relegate
those ideas to third parties it's much
easier for Democrats to ignore them so I
think local level third party's federal
level do everything you can to
progressive eyes the Democratic Party
such that maybe one day we can do real
campaign finance reform and and deal
with the problems of the voting system
that we have send me your thoughts I
know for sure that there are a lot of
people in the audience who just disagree
with me